j'ai connu ça
2 ben ali
savoie partir revenir et repartir encore
pour se former et vivre de sa passion
musicale natacha tortillard évolue ainsi
depuis des années au rythme de cette
intuition professionnels qui en fait
déjà une choriste de reconnu leader à
l'occasion de ces gars 2000 par exemple
elle accompagne aujourd'hui des
chanteurs comme davy sicard baco ou
encore à pollonia répétition scène
enregistrement formation enseignement
elle a trouvé sa voie après avoir osé
frapper un jour à une première porte et
bien longtemps de cela
depuis combien de temps vous faites de
la musique alors je fais de la musique
depuis
enfin si on peut dire que je fais de la
musique depuis
novembre entendait pas loin de chez moi
monsieur en face qui faisait de la
musique et je voulais absolument
apprendre d'accord donc un jour je suis
allé chez lui et j'ai cogné à sa porte
en disant je veux apprendre maman a dit
oui alors que c'était pas vrai et il me
dit je regarde par la fenêtre qu'elle
nous fasse signe et c'est la vérité tu
viens donc je me suis arrangée avec une
de mes soeurs et
elle a dit oui donc je suis allée de 9
ans à 14 ans donc j'ai fait que ça à
chaque fois que je sentais à l'école
j'allais chez ce monsieur il m'apprenait
à faire tout de l'aïd oui cassés
pratiqués comme c'est casse-gueule amis
comme instrument tout l'accordéon la
guitare basse la guitare le piano la
batterie tout au tout l'harmonica enfin
il faisait de tout et je voulais toucher
à tout aussi mais c'était uniquement
delorey quoi cela servait pas forcément
lire la musique ou quoi que ce soit donc
je vous laisse égalé valls est un peu
les trucs de longtemps comme on dit et
on a donné quelques représentations j'ai
joué à l'école de fabreville d'ailleurs
une fête de noël pour les petits je
faisais des saints mais tout ça est ce
que ça a suffi ou a fallu approfondie et
cette connaissance ça suffisait pas non
c'était une base pour dire qu'on pourra
voir l'oreille musicale on va dire pour
bien faire la différence que canaccord
qu'un dos et un dos et qu'un récit et
servira tombe différence et c'est donc
c'était une bonne base c'est vrai mais
on apprend tout le temps mais demain on
apprend toujours toujours on n'a jamais
fini d'apprendre en fait
on sait
plus tard à l'âge de 15 ans je voulais
être indépendante jouer de la guitare
mais j'y arrivais pas j'arrive à ce
qu'il me fallait un modèle et c'est là
que mon cousin ty coat qui est intervenu
il était venu me voir pour qui est monté
son groupe tisse hausse et il voulait
quelqu'un pour jouer au clavier et pour
faire éventuellement un peu de coeur et
je ne me connaissais pas du tout donc
ont commencé à jouer ensemble fut
regardé ce qu'il faisait à l'héritage de
copier sur lui donc toujours on faisait
ça des morceaux
de tout de lui de sa nou sava de basse
terre dont foulée ça craint
quand devient choriste et comment
devient choriste
en fait j'ai pas vraiment choisi d'être
choristes je suis au début je voulais
jouer ensuite on m'a proposé de faire
les choeurs donc ça me plaisait pas ce
que je chante et joue et celia sait rien
à voir donc quand on chante on est
beaucoup enfin c'est un long travail
comme pour être à l'aise pour
pour pouvoir s'exprimer librement et
c'est quand j'ai rencontré bako qui a
cru en quelque chose en moi il m'a
poussé là dedans donc on a mis beaucoup
de temps on a mis à peu près trois
quatre mois à prendre ce répertoire
c'était tous les jours tous les jours et
en plus c'était dans une langue
différente et
donc là j'ai cru aussi parce que je me
suis dit j'y arrive à faire ça c'est
super donc c'est là que ça a commencé là
et puis là c'est tout a débloqué donc
après on venait me chercher vous venez
me chercher il ya des groupes qui me
voyaient sur scène qui venaient me voir
vous faites des kab'in gérer plus de
besoin de vous donc leurs maps est hélas
après j'ai travaillé avec donc j'ai pris
confiance en moi c'est à ce moment là si
les affaires d'une formation pour
complètement il m'en a fallu alors
d'abord ça a été en travaillant sur en
faisant des scènes des scènes ça là on
apprenait dans les mots sur le terrain
on ne devient pas musicienne je pense
pas en et en allant dans une école soit
en lait on n'est pas au fond de soi
d'accord c'est inné alors oui je pense
bon maintenant il ya des gens qui
apprennent de la musique pour par
passion ou pour pour connaître quelque
chose en plus mais
je crois qu'il faut il faut il faut il
faut la revoir en soit on est allé faire
une tournée en belgique avec le groupe
jessica percée et de là on était passé à
paris et là on a pris connaissance qui
avait des écoles de musique avait des
gens qui se former et du jour au
lendemain je me suis dit je veux faire
ça je veux le faire donc j'ai eu à peine
un mois pour préparer tout ça pour faire
la demande de subvention avec le conseil
régional et tout ça et je voulais
tellement y aller que ben j'ai mis le
paquet il ya un mois j'ai une subvention
accordée
donc du coup je suis allé et ça a
commencé là en de bain pour deux années
parlez moi justement de cette fille
d'accord alors c'est une formation qui
qui a duré deux ans donc c'est
renouvelable tous les ans
donc
beaucoup de théorie musicale beaucoup de
théorie donc l'harmonie le solfège et
tout ça et j'avais un cours privé de
chant donc une fois par semaine là on
travaille les techniques vocales et qui
peut se questionner sur la voie quel est
le travail qu'il faut fait en c'est très
technique en fait c'est très technique
alors au début on chante avec ses
émotions c'est d'accord
on
on s'exprime en fait on vous faire
passer à travers savoir ce qu'on se sent
souvent si ça les gens ils disent on
chante parce qu'on a le blues on chante
parce que parce qu'on souffre parce que
enfin tout ça et sans connaître vraiment
le fond c'est-à-dire la théorie musicale
on chante vraiment ce qu'on ressent par
exemple le maori moi j'y comprends rien
forcément si beaucoup de je chante alors
à épais trait phonétique et on se
comprend parce que
bako par exemple avec qui je chante à
maoré c'est quelqu'un qui souffre
énormément qui parle de sa souffrance de
sa vie dans ses morceaux et à travers ça
j'ai pu m'intégrer parce que je
ressentais ça justement donc c'est pour
ça que ce rare et sur dix morceaux par
exemple je pouvais tout c'est faire ça à
sa venue est automatiquement parce que
je le sentais c'est pour ça qu'on dise
que la musique est une langue universel
exactement exactement moi je crois en sa
j'y crois parce que à ce jour eh ben je
sais que je
quelle que soit la langue quel que soit
le l'artiste je pense que je serai m'y
adapter on m'a travers la musique
tout le monde est ma vie c'est bon
et au bout de ces deux ans
à la fin de cette formation mais qu'est
ce qu'on vous a dit alors on m'a dit
qu'il fallait pas retourner à la réunion
il fallait surtout pas faire ça mais je
voulais vous trouvez mon pays je voulais
revenir parce que je savais plus
vraiment me situer en fait c est en ces
termes
c'était très difficile parce que pour se
faire une place en tant que musicien à
paris
il faut
cesser paysans y en a tellement ici oui
ici j'avais une place en tant que
choriste un bon ensuite
on élargit son
ses connaissances
on a envie d'autre chose après donc et
comme on est on est subventionnée
uniquement que deux années au niveau de
cette formation donc soit on avait le on
est et on avait de la chance et puis ça
va on pouvait on pouvait directement
aller se faire suivez plus et ça y est
on y est arrivé
ou alors il fallait se battre mais ce
n'était pas le moment pour moi je pense
pas donc je suis revenu pour
en fait pour savoir vraiment ce que je
voulais depuis votre retour à ce que
vous avez la possibilité de côtoyer les
gens de ma scène oui alors j'ai côtoyé
donc avec eric c'est d'acheter le séga
demi j'ai rencontré des musiciens de
davy sicard
avec qui aujourd'hui je travaille sur un
album donc l'album d'apollonia ont fait
les choeurs ensemble j'ai pu aussi
partir à mayotte avec tholot chamond
chjama aurait qui venu s'installer à la
réunion et que j'avais rencontré à paris
donc comme ils me connaissaient donc on
avait gardé contact et j'ai pu faire ce
travail avec lui j'ai travaillé que les
enfants et
là où je me plaisais et je me suis dit
pourquoi pas
donner des cours
les données des cours il faut parler se
perfectionner davantage se former et là
il ya le du milan c'est un diplôme
universel de musicien intervenant c'est
une formation qui se passe à poitiers et
qui débutera au mois d'octobre donc
ça dure deux ans et suite à ça je
pourrais enseigne
en repartant j'espère rencontrer à
nouveau des gens et
pouvoir pratiquer en fait jouer un
maximum maintenant dans quoi quoi
comment je sais pas je
choisis pas
les choses arrive
ça arrive oui on m'avait dit un jour de
congé il faut jamais aller chercher on
viendra te chercher c'est ce qui s'est
passé en fait et qu'est ce que vous avez
envie de dire aux gens justement qui
vont vite se lancer dans ce domaine
aux jeunes plus particulièrement
que s'ils ont envie de le faire que si
le sens au fond d'eux mêmes il faut y
aller il faut pas avoir honte faut pas
avoir peur il faut il faut se lancer en
fait souvent la peur on à
se cacher à quelque chose on se dit mais
je peux pas je peux pas je peux pas
affronter c'est pas vrai
suffit d'y aller il faut bâtir j'ai
quand les danses maloya
tout le monde y chamaillent pas quand
lee fait son petit tour n'eurent
galimède son mollet
l'une et n'a beaucoup la pause comme
d'antan passicos de bois l'amande